sometimes life
is dealt a certain way you get a certain
hand you know some people choose to
hang up their gloves and retire others
used to go into retirement you know i
mean um
what i choose is they dealt me a hand
and in poker you get your hand you have
the right to
fold your hand and have them deal you
another one you know well the hands
they've been dealing me
the price that i pay when i lose is very
very costly it cost me 17 years of my
life in prison
it cost me my family my loved ones it
cost me my wife my children
my grandchildren it cost a lot a whole
lot in the beginning they never told me
that this is what's gonna happen you
know when you go about uh uh living your
lifestyle in this fashion you know like
i've shared before i'm not i wasn't i
wasn't given the choice to say hey you
want to be a fireman you want to be a
police officer you want to be a lawyer i
don't sit up here and complain or cry
over spilled milk but the thing about it
was is that i was never given that
option the only option i was given was
this is how you're going to be this is
what you do you do not tell you don't
mean you hold your water you know they
gave me so
many rules when i was a young man that
you know a lot of them i took with me
and they helped me through life honestly
i didn't think that i was going to live
class 21
because of the fact that the lifestyle i
chose where i lived at um how many foods
were out to get me for things that i did
to them in the past you know i didn't
feel that i was going to live past 21.
and when 21 came you know i mean 22 came
23 came then when i hit about
28 um realizations started to come like
they peeled the layers off my eyes you
know i mean i started to see things for
what they really were you know i mean i
started to see that no matter how much
[ __ ] i did on the streets or how much
work i put in or how many dudes i hurt
you know um really i didn't get that
credit
somebody else was getting that credit
you know someone else was getting all
the credit when i was putting in all the
work you know what i mean and like i
said when i turned 28
29 years old i came to the realization
that you know what what is what is gang
banging all summed up to be you know
what what what did i benefit
out of it
you know what i benefited
my reputation your reputation exceeds
you you know i mean what i mean by
exceed you is it it gets bigger
than what you actually put out there you
know i'm saying uh dudes i mean i've
been to places where i drove up and and
and everything was cool and i thought oh
man i'm gonna be right here i'm gonna
keep it real low nobody knows me i'm
gonna go under the radar
hell no took one dude to recognize me
him to [ __ ] put it out there throw it
out there and then everything's put on
my lap you know i have responsibility
being a leader or big responsibility
everybody's pointing their finger what i
notice is everybody's pointing their
finger oh you can't do that like you're
not human you know what i'm saying i
don't feel no one's perfect you know
what i'm saying i try to do things as
best i can to get it to perfection but a
lot of dudes are there to criticize you
it's mainly mainly in the game realm you
know everybody wants to be the hood star
you know everybody wants to be the dude
with the biggest gun to do with the
biggest dope the guy with the biggest
sack has the best [ __ ] you know me has
the best woman has a nice car you know
um i i did all that you know my my dream
was to drive a mercedes benz
today i drive a mercedes benz and
believe me
i'll give that car back in a minute just
to get another car because the fact that
i thought i was gonna cruise look good
at 50 years old i'm figuring i'm a
cruise i'ma look good again 50 years old
i'm a grandfather you know the thing
that sticks in my head is what my little
girl told me one time are you done yet
no
she said i asked you that when i was a
little girl if you were done
he said no when i was
gonna be an adult i asked you again
if you were done you said no
now i'm gonna ask you one more time
you're a grandfather
you're not just my father you're not
just somebody's dad you're a grandfather
are you done yet
nah
i'm not done yet
i'm not done here for the simple fact
that like i said before the hardest
thing for me to get rid of is my attire
i try to switch it up and you know maybe
some days just real nice and clear other
days dress
regular and then other days just working
on a car whatever my bike whatever and i
just stayed dirty you know man and you
know recently you know um i never ever
read the comments
on these videos that i've been doing you
know because the fact that you know uh
uh a constructive criticism i'm not too
good at accepting it you know i mean i
know what it kind of pertains around but
i'm not too good at accepting it because
um you know
it hurts you know me i mean i put out
there love hurts period love hurts me
really bad you know i try to stay away
from it i don't have a woman right now
um i have no relationships right now
because the fact that love hurts it
hurts so much that i just want to stay
as far away as possible
of it as i can but just recently
i went and read the comments and i got
up here i get up here and i speak the
real i speak the truth got no reason to
lie [ __ ] anybody because the fact
that there's guys that know me
everywhere and come and do a video up
here and tell you if i was full of [ __ ]
you know i mean well you know uh i read
the comments and
never ever have i felt
that type of love respect and admiration
ever since i i've been a child
you know i mean i don't remember it in
no other
part around in my life you know i read
those comments and i'mma be honest you
know um i shed a tear for the simple
fact that i didn't know that the words i
share with people or the stories i've
told people pertain to them
i mean i don't know what's working i
don't know if it's a higher power or or
or it's some people god jesus whatever i
don't know what it is but
you know um
those comments alone
you know they
they've boosted my morale my self-esteem
most of all my self-respect because
you know i thought people were going to
get up there and be like you're full of
[ __ ] you're a [ __ ] liar you know i
mean no one lives like that i'm here to
tell you yeah
there's people that live like that i
live like that i live like that every
day of my life i've shared with you up
here that i don't look over my shoulder
believe me
i have
always inside me
feeling to look over my shoulder
but why
why do i look over my shoulder for what
you know what i mean a dude you shoot at
me and i could dive to the floor and he
can hit me in my head you know what i'm
saying so you know uh i i i look over my
shoulder and i've heard dudes discuss
that and say that before you know guys
that i've discussed they'd see my
interviews and stuff and they got
questions and they want to ask me and
they always ask me why don't you look
over your shoulder i just feel
comfortable walking down the street not
having to look on my shoulder because
the only time i did over my shoulder
when i was on the run on parole of
scounding running from the cops you know
i've been i've been beat up so bad by
the pro officers you wouldn't believe
the way they beat you up for the simple
fact that
he got mad because i threw a pack of
pampers on him
you know man at the bus stop he tried to
get me i threw the pampers on him and i
took off running they beat me really bad
bruised my ribs i couldn't get up for a
week and a half you know what i mean and
they took me to the federal building
didn't even take me to the state
building took me to the federal building
you know i mean they want to ask me all
kinds of questions and put me under the
microscope and you know i share that
because
you know a lot of young dudes that are
out here they they want to be you know
gang member they want to be with the
business and all that
it's all fine and dandy but you have to
remember there's always a flip side to
the other side of the coin man and that
other side is it's very very very very
dirty
very scandalous you mean uh it's like
it's like people will use you like a
stepping stone just to get to where they
want to go without
no understanding for your family your
loved ones anything they don't care
about who gets hurt
when they hurt you no one really cares
about that you know i mean uh
i was right here for like
five years right here in in skid row you
know and
i got myself out a few months back you
know i mean and uh
you know uh
when i got out of here you know i mean
um there was a little part of me that
missed this
it wasn't the part of getting high
it wasn't a part of running around all
night in the streets
what it was is the feeling
to be needed
and what i mean to be needed is if
you're the dope man well then you're
always needed
you know i mean uh you you can get
information from people from dope you
can you can have them tell you whatever
you want to know
but what i get back to is to feel needed
see
a lot in my life recently
i hadn't been needed my children didn't
need me my ex-wife didn't need me my
girlfriend didn't need me uh but but i
wanted the feeling to feel needed
and you know
getting back to these comments that i
read you know that that's what
these videos have made me feel like i'm
needed you know they they get up there
and and the first words are
man i love you johnny
that [ __ ] blows me out the water like
this person don't even know me
over a cold bowl of mush ned rest passed
me in traffic
never have we made eye contact and said
hello but this person along with
a hundred other people are talking about
we love you bro
i love you bro i can't wait until the
next one of your videos you know i mean
uh get that mark man time to put another
one up there man you know what i mean i
i i wait all week long i go to work bust
my ass but when i get home at night
first thing i go to is
mark's channel you know and i'm looking
honestly i'm looking for you you know
what i mean and and you know other
individuals but maybe you know they're
speaking to me they're telling me i'm
looking for you bro you know me i want
to hear what you got to say and i didn't
feel that i was getting up here um
sharing anything extraordinary you don't
mean anything like mind blowing you know
but i have to understand as well within
myself that
a person is going to perceive my story
any way they choose to perceive it you
know i mean
there's going to be one person out of it
always that says
what the [ __ ] did he say
didn't hear a thing
man the message was probably for that
person you know i mean but you know like
i said everybody perceives it different
you know what i'm saying i i read some
of the i look at some of the stories and
i hear people speaking you know and i
know a lot of people get up here and
speak from their heart and it's
heartfelt because i've been there i've
been in those situations that they're in
you know i mean i've been with women
slinging them on the streets you know i
mean i didn't call myself a pimp but i
was slinging women i was slinging dope
you know i felt that as long as i can
make myself
a product of that environment then i
will always be comfortable regardless of
where i'm at how much money i have as
long as i can make myself a part of that
environment and become a part of it well
then i'll be comfortable you know i'm
saying and once i wanted to be
comfortable and i made myself a product
of that environment
i didn't know that i was setting myself
up for a downfall every time they tell
me you get dope you go out there and
sling it you get busted you get out you
get up again you sleep you get busted
you
you do that repeatedly
or repetitious
what is that saying
is it saying that that i'm in the right
frame of mind
how am i in the right frame of mind if
i'm going out doing something expecting
different results but i get the same
result
and
i'm okay with it you know what i mean
i'll go to jail get clean work out get
out
healthy as [ __ ] again and then do the
same thing again expecting a different
result i told you i've been there
big speed tv badass woman baddest
apartment all that [ __ ] and i'm sitting
there telling myself
this is not supposed to be me
i'm not supposed to be successful
this isn't part of my life you know what
i mean and that was the first thing i
did knocking myself you know and i share
that with a lot of youngsters out there
because you know you'll get to that
point where you'll feel that you're the
man homie
i've been there dog i've been there i
don't get up and and put nobody's name
or any kind of organization or any kind
of group of people but i get up and
speak about myself [ __ ] that i have done
situations that i've been in [ __ ] that
i've run i'm not getting up here and
saying um anybody no inside i still feel
special
and i still feel that i'm somebody me
myself you know what i mean that's from
the comments i read you know the
opportunity that you have given me mark
to be up here and and speak my mind
freely
freely you know i've seen a lot of
interviews where
you have to shoot questions to these
people and you have to you know keep
them going me
i just keep it going because it's the
honest truth
it's what i'm sharing with you it it all
this has transpired in my life there's
so much more that has taken place you
know me but i have to be very careful
that i don't
give a story and involve
someone else that doesn't want no
involvement with this you know my
grandmother told me a long time ago if
you do something you get away with it
why are you gonna go talk about it again
it's like doing it all over again why in
the [ __ ] did you do in the first place
if you wanted to get away with it when
you talk about it again it's like it's
like redoing it all again and you're
giving up right information you're
liable to get busted you don't mean and
you know i i went with that all my life
and it's worked it's worked for me you
know i mean i don't know it works for
anybody else but you know when i get
there and i hear the videos and people
are talking
and i hear them and then i hear you ask
a question i'm like
wait up i was doing an interview you
know a interview is you're giving an
interview and i'm a strong believer that
i don't want to lose you through the
interview i don't want to have you
yawning want to change the channel go to
another dude no i want you on the edge
of your seat
every time i want you to sit there and
hear what i got to share with you you
know me where i got to share with you
where this came from
years and years of my family's
preparation for all my cousins all my
brothers you know we're all lined up
this is what you're going to be you're
going to be a gang member and there's
nothing else i get up there and share
this with people because
you know honestly people can say oh no
you're full of [ __ ] and you can be
anything you want
okay
i'll give you that but now if you got a
gang of adults
that are your family members that you
rely on that you trust and love and put
your life on the line for
then why wouldn't you believe anything
they're telling you why wouldn't you
believe that you know hey uh you know
you're going to get these tattoos you're
going to go to jail you know i mean
you're going to be from this gang and
that's what's going to happen you know
why wouldn't i believe them
they're all like god they're all i know
they're they're the only ones that give
me vital information that's going to
pertain to my life and when they told me
this is what you're going to be this is
what you're going to do
that's all i felt i was going to do i
was going to be yeah i went to school i
went to school and and and took some
classes some courses different [ __ ] you
know dialectical behavior thinking chain
analysis all this [ __ ] you know mind
mapping i did all i took all these
classes but never in my life has anybody
prepared me in a way that my family
prepared me and believe me mark they're
they're upset there's a few of them out
there of my family members that are
really upset because they heard these
videos and they see me up here telling
the [ __ ] truth letting people know
what kind of individuals they are
you know because you don't tell a 10 11
year old kid
that they're going to be a gang member
they're going to be nothing else
you know no one has that right in the
world to tell
an individual that let alone a child you
know i'm saying that i told you a few
minutes ago i've never felt this type of
love ever since i've been a kid why
because i was never given that type of
love
the type of love i was given was heart
[ __ ] love this is the kind of love
you're getting take it or leave it but
this is the kind you're going to get
you're not going to get anything else
you know and they're upset and believe
me half of them don't talk to me half of
them they
don't want to speak to me
and half of it is because
they're [ __ ] scared
why are you scared of a [ __ ] person
that you created
you know that that that's what that's
what gets me the most you know they're
upset
because they don't want to be around me
because they can't trust my movements or
they can't trust my judgment or they
can't be around me because they feel i'm
going to get them in trouble
but you created this [ __ ] monster
you're the reason
you're more the reason i am who i am
today but yet
my cousin just died last week
wasn't able to see him he had four stage
four stage cancer wasn't able to go see
him because of the way these [ __ ]
people feel you know what i mean didn't
go to his funeral
because they had a [ __ ] list on who
the [ __ ] they wanted to go and then
you couldn't wear
jeans and a t-shirt no they don't want
nobody in jeans and a t-shirt they want
everybody in a tire that you feel is
appropriate
appropriate
how the [ __ ] are you going to say
appropriate when
you [ __ ] straight
maybe the person i am today
showed me what to wear
my cousin's my homeboy he's a gang
member then you want to turn around and
tell us that we can't wear a certain
attire to attend his funeral but it was
okay in the beginning when you know you
wanted to make me shine and fix me up
like a cholo and all that now you're
telling me
15 20 years later that i can attend a
funeral because i can't wear jeans and a
white t-shirt
you know that that's what that's what
hurts me the [ __ ] most is that my
[ __ ] so-called family
say they love me but the only time they
ever [ __ ] need me is like two weeks
ago when my [ __ ] niece couldn't find
her son vayne talked to me for nothing
my sister's a [ __ ] millionaire she
didn't talk to me for [ __ ] but then my
niece can't find her son so what do they
do they call my daughter talking about
hey can you tell your dad
if he could find my son and send him
home
[ __ ] i ain't even got a home
let alone me going getting someone else
and sending them home you know what the
[ __ ] were these people when i needed
them the most when i was down and out at
the bottom
they weren't around but it just it
[ __ ] strikes me really hard that they
will turn around and want me to go find
their son and send him home
so that so that's all you want me for
you want me for nothing else there's
nothing of value there's nothing of
credibility that you could come about
and say well this is what we want you
for no all they [ __ ] wanted me was to
go in whoever's hood he was in
go and find them
why because i can do that and they can
wait that's their son that's their
[ __ ] son they should go find him
would you send me in the [ __ ] lion's
den
to go find him and take him out now i
didn't tell him that i found him but i
found him and i sent his [ __ ] ass
home
i didn't go in to them and tell him hey
i found him give me the credit for
[ __ ] what credit ain't no [ __ ]
credit there i found
my my my niece's son i found him sent
him home never gave him
any reason why or nothing never told him
it was me mark for the simple fact that
you know they've used me for so long
just like your homies will use you in
the hood for so long you know you have
to understand that everybody's
replaceable
everybody you know me you get busted
today flocco and flock are out there on
the street corner slinging go do 10
years you get out
flock one fl oh excuse me little flocco
and little flakka are out there on the
corner now slinging
same [ __ ] corner same [ __ ] dope
just two different people why because
they're replaceable you you become
replaceable
they you know it's it's like a gang
you don't run out of people you know you
don't run out of people they're there
you know some are there to volunteer
their time some of you get forced
somewhere just made the way this is how
you're gonna have it you know i mean and
that's how it's gonna be you know what i
mean and and you know i
there there's so many things that now
that i did these videos and i've
listened to myself speak and i've
listened to other gentlemen and that
you've had up here and other women that
you've had up here and i've listened to
them speak you know and and i've also
learned a lot from them i also learned
that
i wasn't the only [ __ ] that was
dealt this [ __ ] up handmark there's a
lot of [ __ ] people that you have put
on the screen that were doubt a [ __ ]
up hand you know i mean people that have
been abused by their own family members
you know what i'm saying i got abused
the same way but just not in that
fashion
not sexually or mentally mine was more
or less i got abused but i got abused in
a fashion where
they set my life up
and that's what it consists of
that's it you know i mean there's
there's no there's no handouts they
don't come and and turn around and pull
around the corner say hey
encore because here's some money you
hungry
[ __ ] no they ain't gave me nothing in
the last
15 20 years and and believe me my family
is deep we got a lot of [ __ ] a lot of
[ __ ] family a whole lot and a lot of
them are very well off but yet they
never ever come and just here man here's
a few dollars man
buy something you know you need some gas
you know you need anything like right
now you know uh i have a storage you
know what i'm saying and uh you know i
pay the storage myself you know and uh
just recently i paid 560 late fees
two days later they auction off my
storage
right in front of me [ __ ] dude sells
it i [ __ ] get up go look dude's all
in my [ __ ] has it lined up all the way
to his truck and i tell him what the
[ __ ] are you doing
what the [ __ ] are you doing my first
thing was to break this [ __ ] off
because that's what i know i know break
this [ __ ] up take all your [ __ ]
and take his [ __ ] too
but the man said i bought it
i went to the manager went to the place
and said hey uh
dudes in my [ __ ] i just paid you 560
dollars dude said you just sold in my
[ __ ] storage for 300 bucks
oh we made a mistake
the lady started crying i told her those
tears right there crocodile tears you
can save those [ __ ] because
what you cannot replace is one thing you
have to understand that i have my ashes
from my family members inside my storage
this individual spilled them on the
floor
i can't sweep them up i can't sweep them
up i said the following week i had to go
sit
at dinner with just a couple of my
family members
and explain to them
how i lost
my cousin's ashes
how they hit the [ __ ] ground and i
can't [ __ ] sweep them up
these people in storage don't know the
value of the stuff that i had in there
and they can't [ __ ] replace the [ __ ]
you know and now they tell me i got to
tonight mark
to get my [ __ ] out of there
i got something i had to get my [ __ ] out
of there till uh nine o'clock tonight to
get my [ __ ] out there you know and um
you know i went and looked for another
storage you know because there's stuff
that's in there of value
that's been in my family for a long time
that i cannot lose
these people almost sold it i cannot
lose it so you know i have to go about
taking care of that making sure that i
don't lose this and at the same time you
know i'm trying to get some some some
legal advice because the fact that
they auctioned off my storage and i paid
my bill
you know what i'm saying they breached
contract and all that [ __ ] but yet
just three days ago he comes and tells
me oh man you got until the 31st man
when a week previous
because he [ __ ] saw my storage he
told me
on the first i'll get your own storage
hook you up your own in your own name
now all of a sudden he flipped the
script because i went and asked for
their
uh uh um for their company's insurance
and shot me down he didn't want to give
it to me
i was told by you know legal
representation that if he shoots you
down let us know so that's why i'm at
right now but the thing about is that
you know
it's so [ __ ] up because
even if sometimes when you become a gang
member and you're doing your thing you
have to understand that sometimes you'll
be going steady you'll be going steady
you'll be going steady and then boom
they throw a log right in front of you
and you have to overcome that you have
to either jump the [ __ ] cut the
[ __ ] move it out the way however
you're gonna do it but you know just
recently you know uh
560 dollars man for storage
and they [ __ ] sell it two days later
you know um my first thing was to go
back to the old guy was you know the uh
casper that gang member and break this
[ __ ] off you know what i mean
and take whatever he had because of
simple fact then my second thing was do
i call the police
being a gang member we don't call the
police but it was a crime committee you
know being that they went in there sold
my [ __ ] was there a crime committed but
again being that i'm a gang member being
that i've been taught that we're the
police you don't need to call the law my
first thing was
i'll hesitate to even get on the phone
and dial 9-1-1 because what the [ __ ] am
i doing dialing 9-1-1
that's not in my that's not in my my
makeup that's not in my body build-up
you know i mean i don't get on the phone
and call 9-1-1 if you're my family
member you have a problem
my number was 9-1-1 that's who you call
you call me you don't call nobody else
you know man i got a gun just as big as
that [ __ ] cop does you know me
maybe even more bullets than he got but
i'm just sharing that because this is
what a gang member consists of there's
so many things you know i mean uh if
your family your mom and dad gets robbed
and they call the police
and dude gets busted i'm sitting with
him in jail
no your mom and dad are rats
how the [ __ ] is that possible mark how
the [ __ ] is your mom and dad rats when
your father pays his bills pays his
taxes your mother pays her taxes pays
her bills they bought their home they
respect their neighbors they [ __ ]
donate to charities
but the rats
why because their their home got robbed
and their thing is down 9-1-1 because
that's what the police is there for to
protect and serve the ones that cannot
be protected
you mean to serve the ones that need to
be served but yet we'll sit in jail and
dudes talking about your mom and dad are
rats man you better [ __ ] go to town
not to show up to court man
what the [ __ ] are you talking about
my mom and dad ain't rats my mom and dad
[ __ ] work man they [ __ ] got their
home because your punk ass homeboy
decided to break in there and want to
steal all the christmas presents what
do you think that's [ __ ] cool at
christmas that your homeboy breaks the
window steals all the christmas presents
they got to re-buy them now but now my
mom and dad are rats see i share that
with with with the young gentlemen that
that are wanting to be gang members and
wanting to get in business you have to
remember there's a lot of [ __ ] that
comes with this a lot of [ __ ] you know
i'm pretty sure you ain't gonna sit
there and let a [ __ ] call your
mom and dad a rap and probably uh uh you
know play with their lives you know what
i'm saying because a rat needs to get
rid of you know and for them to say
about your mom and dad and your mom and
dad were only doing the right thing
calling to get protected and served but
now they're wrong you know there's a lot
of [ __ ] that [ __ ] won't sit up
here and tell you and share with you i'm
not saying they got the balls i'm not
saying they ain't got the audacity i'm
more or less saying if you're gonna get
up here you're gonna speak speak the
real you know what i mean give the good
and bad just don't give the good and
leave the [ __ ] bat out you know what
i mean there's a lot of [ __ ] [ __ ]
that you know
in the future i will share i will share
you know what i mean and there's a lot
of dudes out there that oh man come over
here and do this and do that no like i
told you before mark i'm a loyal
[ __ ] man you know what i mean
the reason i'm getting my message across
is because you allowed me the time and
understanding to get my message across
you know i felt that in the beginning a
lot of people already thought i was just
gonna get up here and glorify what it is
to be a gang member no i'm gonna get up
here and tell you
what it's really [ __ ] like what
[ __ ] don't tell you i'm not
gonna give you vital information that or
get me hurt or get someone else hurt no
i'm gonna give you vital information
that might even pertain and save your
life one day you know the guy might be
listening right now a youngster 13 14
years old
and he's saying damn
i didn't know all this comes with what i
want to be
yeah it's there and it waits it doesn't
go nowhere it's right there and it
doesn't give a [ __ ] how old you are
doesn't give [ __ ] what color you are
just different what sex you are you
don't give you're gay you're straight
lesbian it doesn't matter it doesn't
matter it has no conscience
just steady and steady eats your [ __ ]
life up little by little it takes pieces
and pieces to where eventually all you
got is a little piece left and you're
trying to protect that with everything
you got but [ __ ] are just
nicking away at it nicking away at it
and then what's really [ __ ] up is from
within
it's making away from the other side so
you know it's getting hit from both ends
you know and i'm one to say because the
fact that you know i had to go through a
process and realize
who the [ __ ] did i create why did i
create this monster who had
part in this to make me the man i am
today to make me you know uh uh get up
there and speak about things that other
[ __ ] will feel ill about
they can't get up here and say well yeah
homie i lost this time i got god you
know by [ __ ] this little you know what
i mean they won't come through and say
that because they don't want to feel in
no way oh man a little bit tarnished
tarnish me you know they just want to
shine they won't get they won't get
there and tell you that a [ __ ] other
dude skinny as [ __ ] put a big ass gun
and took all the money in your pocket
[ __ ] won't get up here and say
that i will because i've gotten got like
that before and i've got [ __ ]
like that before you live by a sword you
die by the sword you don't mean you live
by the gun you die by the gun you know
what i'm saying and that's just the way
it is you know i'll get up and tell you
that i got burned so [ __ ] good
where
i sat there and i shed a tear because of
what i lost and it was material
but yet because it was mine because i
obtained it and because they got me so
good for it
i felt a shame i felt embarrassed you
mean most of all
i felt like
how in the [ __ ] could i allow a
[ __ ] to get me
you know i mean that's how i felt look
at me looking i'm gonna tell you who i
think i am you know i mean but
just by the way i speak
and the way my reputation you'll know
exactly who i am
but honestly most of the time people get
up here and sit here and tell you
who they think they are you know i mean
who i think i am but if i ask you right
now you ask me the question right now
who are you
i don't know
i can't hear people tell you
there's one question that
i've been asked several times and i
ain't got an answer i ain't got an
answer yet
you know i can't tell you i'm a father
that's a [ __ ] lie i mean i can't tell
you that i'm somebody's husband that's a
[ __ ] lie i can tell you that this is
my friend it's a [ __ ] lie
you know what i'm saying it i i can't
get up here and tell you things because
the fact that majority of them are
[ __ ] lies man
they're [ __ ] all [ __ ] lies
majority of them but when i get up and
speak soulfully about me
that's where all
the truth comes out that's for all the
understanding where you know if
someone's going to speak you can you can
see you can read them
you can see if i'm all focused up here
bullshitting oh my focus up you're
telling the real i get up here and tell
the real the [ __ ] i tell you the large
ball those are the shits that a
[ __ ] wants to tell you he thinks
he is you know what i mean
i know who i am today and you know i
want to get up here and share about
about these videos because you know i
see a lot of
you know complaints
crybabies whatever you want to call them
haters you know
if they were so [ __ ] concerned about
what you're doing or what i'm doing well
then they would have been doing what the
[ __ ] we're doing right now you know they
should be so concerned about what the
[ __ ] we're doing why are you up in our
[ __ ] [ __ ] when we ain't going out
there looking for you
you know from my understanding i see
[ __ ] lined up coming over here
i don't see much if you go finding
[ __ ] putting fliers up on the
[ __ ] pole no [ __ ] are coming
here you know what i mean and i i like i
said i'm up here to tell the real i'm up
here to let him know how it really is
i'm not here to brown those or shine
nobody up nah i fear you shine i shine
if i shine you shine that's just the way
it is but you know you got a lot of
people that want to make the remarks and
hate from the sidelines
but you have the you have the
[ __ ]
right to do the same thing we're [ __ ]
doing it's just you don't want to do the
footwork a lot of [ __ ] don't
want to do the footwork they want to
just get up here and [ __ ] you know
they just want to give me give me give
me but what are you giving what are you
really giving are you really giving a
part of you or are you just giving some
[ __ ] [ __ ] ass story because you
want to just give bush a story and get
on
every time i'm set up here i came from
the heart i came from the heart and let
it be known like i said
a lot of people are upset
i can't help that i can't make them feel
happy or make them feel sad that's their
own emotion i can only say what i feel
and whatever they get off that whichever
way they feel after that
is no concern of mine i can't allow them
to let their problems
soak inside my brain and allow them to
[ __ ] rent space in here when they
didn't even pay the toll
you got to pay the toll to be up in here
i just can't allow you up in here
because there's one cell and it's mine
then when there's no room for anybody
else
unless i want to request
a cellmate or i want somebody with me
other than that this [ __ ] cell right
here belongs to me you know what i'm
saying and that's all i want i want no
other [ __ ] area
five feet each way and i'm cool you know
what i mean but i share that because the
fact that you know this is a cell i'm up
here and and i create my own world in
here you mean it it's all me you know
there's no room for anybody else you
know what i mean there's no room for
anybody at all you know and i share it
because
just recently i've come to understand
where
uh
people got [ __ ] love uh i hate love all
i just
don't want no part of it i want no part
of it but just recently man when i read
those [ __ ] comments man the [ __ ]
love was there was so [ __ ] strong
that
i forgot what it felt like i honestly
forgot what real love felt like
and i don't fake [ __ ] love what
[ __ ] can tell you he loves you
then you turn around he [ __ ] looks
you pins you up and down from your
[ __ ] feet to your [ __ ] head when
you turn around when you're not looking
not that type of fake ass love i'm
talking about the type of love where
it's unconditional it has no boundary
has no boundary you know people just say
it and from them saying it it touched my
heart where i tell you after five
comments i had to put the phone down
i couldn't control my emotions because
you know my life has consists of nothing
but [ __ ] gang member nothing but
[ __ ] hurting people not people
[ __ ] robbing people
nothing but hurting people's family
members that's all my life has
consistent it hasn't consist of nothing
else i've never got up and spoke and
touched somebody in their heart [ __ ] no
if i was going to touch them i wanted to
touch them so [ __ ] hard that they
would feel me for a long [ __ ] time in
other words that would hurt them really
really [ __ ] bad and wouldn't give a
[ __ ] wouldn't care what you felt or
anybody else felt i'll just hurt a
[ __ ] and move on to the next
[ __ ]
but now that i did these videos and now
that i have a lot of times you listen to
him go back and hear what i said you
know um
it gave me
more gratitude within myself that
you know um
i could wake up in the morning and look
in the mirror now
and really look at myself
before i i didn't see myself like i
don't see my teardrop same [ __ ] it's not
there i don't see it it's there i'll see
it though but now i can get up in the
morning actually look in the mirror and
and really
know who i really am you know what i'm
saying know who i really am within
myself
i if you ask me the question again who
are you
well i'm a gang member
yeah your food say i'm an ex-gang member
no
no no no no don't let them
put that [ __ ] label on you
i'm an ex-gang member you don't gotta
say nothing like that
you know dudes get up there and they're
doing videos and they they fix their
life and everything get high and then
they get up and say uh
uh are you a gang member i'm an ex-gang
member so you're admitting
that you're a gang member you're
admitting that's admit right there
you're admitting that you're a gang
member you know i don't get up there and
say i'm an ass gang i don't know i get
up here and say i'm gonna be 50 years
old and i'm still active i don't mean
i'm out there [ __ ] rolling around
with a pistol spinning like john wayne
no nothing like that what i mean is
when the time comes down to it i'm gonna
be right there i'm not gonna run i'm not
gonna hide look on my shoulder none of
that [ __ ]
i'm who i am today
because of the things i've did in the
past
like i said i'll probably spill milk on
[ __ ] and complain
all i go back to
is the beginning
you know they never allowed me the
opportunity man
to be who the [ __ ]
i wanted to be
and it's kind of late in life now to try
and go back and start restart
again and people say oh you can start
right now i hear you i hear you you
start right now but
the [ __ ] [ __ ] you dragged behind
that [ __ ] luggage that you pull
the [ __ ] [ __ ] is long and there's a
line of [ __ ] man that are just
waiting for a [ __ ] to slip you
know me and my homeboy were attending a
spot that only me and him went to
they killed him last week
shot him four times in the chest
a [ __ ] called him to the car dude came
out the bushes
and [ __ ] kill my homie
now remember
only me and him
attended that spot
so that spot was for either him or i
i didn't go to that place for 10 days
not any specific reason
i just didn't go
10 days later
it took a week
just
to let the [ __ ] news know who my
homie was took him a whole week to
identify him
that's how that's how that's how these
[ __ ] put their [ __ ] together it
was so tight that it took him a whole
week just to identify my homie
and he [ __ ] works there
you see what kind of life game members
live he [ __ ] is employed there and it
took him a [ __ ] week
to find out who he was
and he killed him in front of his face
and of employment
what kind of [ __ ] [ __ ] is that you
know i beg to differ
i tend to ask the question
homie's employed there and took you away
to identify his body when he killed him
right in front of the [ __ ] place he's
worked at
you know what i'm saying with a brand
new [ __ ] car you know they shot him
four times in the chance for the 45
killed him on the spot
then again i go back and i tell you
remember when your reputation exceeds
you remember i was sharing you know that
you do all this [ __ ] and then the long
one's gonna bite you in the ass you know
i seen this [ __ ] dude face to face
and i know this [ __ ] i beat him
up
but wait a minute he's only 20 years old
how could i beat him up 20 years ago
how is that possible i know it's him
because i know his [ __ ] face i beat
him up
so i went back guys
this [ __ ] his dude's son i beat
his dad up
it's just that 20 years later he's
looking at me i'm pulling out of my car
with my girl he steps right in front of
my car
ran for the bumper goes down to tie his
shoe
no pulling out get the [ __ ] out of my
way dude
ties his shoe
stands up
looks around
goes down to ty's other [ __ ] shoe
in front of my [ __ ] car i don't pull
it off from the liquor store i'm about
to run he pulls down the tights other
[ __ ] shoe now believe me mark
my way of thinking is
if she wasn't sitting in this [ __ ]
car i'll use this [ __ ] as a speed bump
back and forth back and forth
for the simple fact that
he's disrespecting me to the fullest
especially when i'm with a woman
he's lucky
that she was there because bottom line
i don't trust her
not with my life
if i run dude over
whom i say she ain't will say something
you know what i mean i might as well
throw her in for the car running her
over too you know i mean i'm just being
honest
but dude [ __ ] did that
and
my first instinct was to run his [ __ ]
ass over
run this [ __ ] what the [ __ ] this
little [ __ ] kid think he is but when
i put it all together
he's upset because i beat up his dad
20 years ago
and i'm looking at this [ __ ] face to
face my hand well i we lock eyes man and
i know this [ __ ] nah man it's
his dad that i know
but just look 20 years later got nothing
to do with this kid he [ __ ] wants to
get right in front of my [ __ ]
car
and he was this [ __ ] close man
to probably losing his life to tell you
the truth is this [ __ ] close man
[ __ ] don't get that close very
often
very often and it gets me upset because
it hurts inside because i know
that just one little [ __ ] spark
would have had me run this [ __ ] over
you know i mean and
i shouldn't think like that but because
of the fact that
gang member my respect my honor who the
[ __ ] gonna tell you who i am
i can't allow a [ __ ] to do that
you know what i mean
i allowed him to do that and i let it go
i let it go
but then i noticed they started tripping
trying to tell my homie they're tripping
he paid no heat to my warning he's no
longer here with us
and that's no secret you know that she
came on the news and everything and i'm
not gonna say who did this or who did
that not mommy got killed
the [ __ ] know who i'm talking
about the [ __ ] know me
personally to see me there you know the
[ __ ] i'm talking about comes around goes
around but anyways
besides that you know these
[ __ ] you know uh just utilized
my past
to put me in a position and try to get
me caught up because of the [ __ ] i did
in the past and that [ __ ] haunts you man
i get up and i share i can say it over
and over again explain it in so many
different ways
remember when you make that decision man
to be that person you want to be man my
best advice is
be all you can be and more
give it a hundred [ __ ] percent
don't have step nothing because this is
a very [ __ ] dangerous game
this [ __ ] could cost your life
in so many [ __ ] aspects
death penalty life without
your [ __ ] last dying breath
all your loved ones and your family and
your freedom
there's no other price
i'm here to say there's no other [ __ ]
price
there's no [ __ ] palace with gold
toilets no
against your [ __ ] paradise
no
no
all this will await you is [ __ ]
sorrow
sadness
loss
all that [ __ ] comes in hand in hand with
this
you know
believe me there's good times oh yeah
everybody has good times
but for some reason the bad overcomes
the good
tenfold tenfold believe me i'll be gonna
tell you tenfold that [ __ ] comes and
that [ __ ] does not stop
it's like on swift wings it just comes
and
next year you're like [ __ ] they want to
give me [ __ ] 15 years
for a [ __ ] 20 of glass
20 of glass that's like that much
wanna give me 15 years they end up
giving me seven
i did seven okay for 20 of glass you
know if i get busted with a 20-year
glass right now you know what they do
don't do it again
when [ __ ] 10 years ago they gave me
seven [ __ ] years with 80 percent now
you want to catch me with even more and
go
don't do it again
what happened to the seven years of my
life you [ __ ] took
you don't see that's what i understand
that's what's so [ __ ] up for a gang
member as well
15 years ago you gave me [ __ ] want to
give me 15 [ __ ] years give me seven
years with 80 for a 20 of glass now
today i get buses walking down the
street with a third of glass and they're
going to slap my hand take me to the
station or even right psyche me out
right there on the spot
when they gave me [ __ ] seven years
just some years back
that was so [ __ ] up at and i share
that with people you know they slap you
on the [ __ ] hand for possession
they gave me the first time they gave me
seven with 80 the second time they gave
me four with 80
years for a [ __ ] little bad ass issue
that today they slapped you on the hand
it's so [ __ ] up the government's so
[ __ ] up society's so [ __ ] up
mainly when you're a gang member it's
[ __ ] up
because they add everything you get
caught with a gun
10 years you get caught with a gun with
a bullet inside it
25 what the [ __ ]
one bullet went from
from [ __ ] 10
to 25
for one bullet
and if you have one chamber
oh my god
i don't even know if you're gonna see
daylight again why because you're past
you're a gang member
and they put that gang enhancement gang
charges you know you have to remember
you have that behind you when you become
a gay member all that you get busted for
a crime remember it's either gonna be
five or ten they're gonna enhance you
because of the fact you're a gang member
and i'm not getting up here speaking
about [ __ ] that i heard no i'm getting
her speaking about [ __ ] that i've
experienced
i did my [ __ ] years
for being a gang member you know i'm
saying oh let's give him five more just
for being a gang member oh and add a
year on for his first prison prior you
know and to them you know from 15 to 20
don't sound different to them but to a
[ __ ] who's getting the time
15 to 20 is a big [ __ ] difference you
know what i mean that's a long [ __ ]
time you know my little girl's doing 20.
you know what i mean she got
maybe seven more left
but she's doing 20.
you know what i mean and she
scored them for what they had her for
she came up you know she
she
she got out
better than what she was i think i
thought she was gonna get but you know i
share that because look what it is even
my little girl
is a gang member man
doing 20 [ __ ] years who might blame
me
society
gang members the law who am i to blame
is it my fault is it really my fault
is it really
did did my genes really rub off on her
from what they tell me she's like me
because me
do i
do i honestly
believe that
that my little girl is doing 20 years
for two murders because
what her dad used to be or where her dad
was in the past
my jeans really rubbed off on her that
that deep
where she got her own mind her own heart
but yet i'm the reason she's doing 20
years for murders it's my fault because
that's what they tell me today
tell me today that's my fault
that she's sitting where she's sitting
oh no mark i can't tell you if it is or
it isn't they just constantly put it out
there
that's your fault man it's your fault
your fault
how's it my fault
oh look you used to be i'm not admitting
to nothing
i'm not saying i was anything or did
anything
but because of my reputation and because
of my past
[ __ ] just want to put me out
there and say oh she's sitting in there
because you
you know and i share that because
you know
every time i get the opportunity to come
up and share things
with you mark and you know and the
people that subscribe to your channel
you know i share with you guys [ __ ] that
is real [ __ ] that is taking place in my
life [ __ ] that i cannot erase no more
[ __ ] that i can't make any better
because it's already all [ __ ] up
you know but remember you know when
you're out there doing your thing and
you're having children whatever happens
to your children you're going to be to
blame they're going to blame you if you
want to be a gay member you're going to
get blamed that your kid got in the gang
my daughter's not even from my dad she's
from a whole different gang but yet it's
my fault that she became a gang member
and my fault where she sits today
you know and asked myself
am i the one to really blame
oh no mark you know i just
get up here you know and like i say
there's not
anything i can tell you or anything i
can say to show my appreciation
for what you did for me all these
half-stepping [ __ ] all these
liars that come up here and all these
[ __ ] bullshitty [ __ ] that
run their mouth don't even know you
personally
i could give a [ __ ] what they say you
mean because my understanding my report
with you is ours
whatever they got to say on the sideline
that's where they're at they're in the
peanut gallery they're on the nose lead
section there's no room for them right
here because to tell you the truth
this foot this spot's only for the sexy
people all the other [ __ ] to
stand to the side you know what i'm
saying mark i'm just being real you know
why i speak real me and you we we talk
real only sexy people are right here man
you just don't room for anybody else you
know i mean this is
our domain so whatever these fools say
or whatever they share whatever [ __ ]
comments they have
waiting to see them keep them sell them
put them in your pocket i could give a
[ __ ] because i know the real i know the
real i'm here i see i observe i'm
looking i i see what's going on these
[ __ ] are talking they're just
from the sideline you know what i mean
but what really is is in the long run
it's all going to reveal itself
because
one don't come out in the wash will
surely come out of the [ __ ] ranch you
know what i mean it will you know what i
mean it will
come to light and everybody will see
what it really is you know what i mean
and
i'ma continue to come for as long as you
choose to have me here and i'll come and
i'll share different [ __ ] every time
sometimes please people understand that
i'm thinking so much and my eyes are
closed because i'm deep in thought you
know what i'm thinking okay have i
shared this before or haven't i you know
but i want to share it because i don't
want anybody to miss
what's there for them and the [ __ ] is
free you know they say game is to be
sold not told i'm believing that
if i was given a game it's only right
for me to give it away if you don't
share it you can't enjoy it man
i share the day because i enjoy it i
read the comments and that's where my
joy for enjoyment comes from
nowhere else you know what i'm saying it
comes from within as long as i can share
it
then i can enjoy it you know me mark
thank you brother huh you're the best
thank you thank you
you